[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález cinco años han
pasado desde la firma del acuerdo de paz
en colombia' un acuerdo histórico que
puso fin a la guerrilla más antigua de
la región la antigua guerrilla de las
farc y también puso fin a 50 años de
enfrentamientos que dejó miles de
víctimas a pesar del resultado del
plebiscito y también a la oposición que
hubo en el proceso el entonces
presidente de colombia juan manuel
santos y el líder de la entonces
guerrilla de las farc rodrigo londoño
firmaron un extenso documento que puso
en marcha mecanismos como el desarme de
la guerrilla la creación de diferentes
instituciones que permitieron llevar a
colombia a una transición también hubo
perdón de las víctimas oa las víctimas y
creación de un nuevo partido político y
también la investigación de diferentes
crímenes en el marco de esta
conmemoración el hoy ex presidente juan
manuel santos se refirió a este proceso
escuchemos
creo que él ha cumplido y está
comprometido con ese objetivo sigue
remando como sigue remando yo como
espero que sigamos remando todos los
colombianos es que es absurdo que
alrededor de un objetivo tan
importante como es el objetivo de la paz
los colombianos estemos divididos en su
también rodrigo londoño el antiguo líder
de la guerrilla de las farc incursionó
en la escena política de colombia con la
creación del partido comunes londoño
también se refirió a este proceso que ha
tenido a lo largo de estos cinco años
escuchemos sus palabras no han sido
fáciles estos años por cuenta de los
incesantes incesantes ataques contra el
acuerdo y la falta de voluntad del
estado para su implementación
integral
aún así
manifestamos que nada ni nadie podrá
admirar nuestra convicción de que el
camino emprendido es el correcto
insistimos en pedir perdón a las
víctimas de nuestras acciones durante el
conflicto
la comprensión de su dolor crece a
diario en nosotros y nos llena de la
fricción y de vergüenza y por supuesto
también el actual presidente de colombia
iván duque se refirió al acuerdo como
una victoria colectiva su gobierno en
algunos momentos ha sido señalado de no
estar impulsando lo suficientemente
rápido la implementación de este pacto
desde el gobierno destacan los avances
que ha habido a lo largo de estos años
aunque también las críticas han llovido
a los integrantes de esta antigua
guerrilla escuchemos al presidente
colombiano iván duque
aquí no se trata de alcanzar triunfos
individuales sino de alcanzar una
verdadera victoria colectiva
porque colombia necesita sacudirse para
siempre de la violencia del narcotráfico
y otras expresiones que a lo largo de
nuestra historia nos han dejado muchos
muchos momentos de desolación en el alma
pues cinco años después hacemos balance
de lo que ha representado la firma de
este acuerdo para colombia' los retos
también esas dificultades que ha tenido
en su implementación como por ejemplo el
narcotráfico se mantiene los grupos al
margen de la ley ganaron terreno algunos
de los 13 mil combatientes desarmados
retomaron la vida subversiva pero hay
que destacar el reconocimiento que han
recibido las víctimas tanto por parte
del grupo armado como por el estado
colombiano y otro sinnúmero de aspectos
que vamos a destacar a lo largo de este
programa tenemos poco más de 30 minutos
para analizar un acuerdo una
implementación de cinco años para
analizar este tema hemos invitado al
león valencia agudelo director y
fundador de la fundación paz y
reconciliación él se encuentra en la
ciudad de bogotá también está con
nosotros eduard rodríguez representante
a la cámara en el congreso de colombia
por el partido oficialista centro
democrático y en el estudio de france 24
nos acompaña nardi vargas cáceres ella
es analista en temas de seguridad
también es integrante del grupo de
investigación en conflictos armados
construcción de paz
dos globales en seguridad de la
universidad de los andes que está
ubicada en la ciudad de bogotá en la
capital colombiana ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y
preguntas lo pueden hacer ya lo saben a
través de las redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram y en
twitter estamos como france24 guión bajo
s arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de estos medios comienzo con león en la
ciudad de bogotá preguntándole
rápidamente y muy puntual cuál es el
balance que usted hace de estos cinco
años de implementación de este acuerdo
de paz en colombia'
pues que el presidente eduque y su
gobierno y el partido de gobierno han
hecho una grave interferencia en el
proceso de paz en el proceso de
reconciliación
y por eso en
unos leños que quedaron prendidos
todavía el gran incendio que había
cuando se firmó el acuerdo de paz ese
incendio que el proceso de paz
lo apagó hasta cierto punto pero no
leyes prendidos y se han vuelto a
fuerzas o leños lln
las disidencias de las farc y la muerte
de líderes sociales la muerte de ex
combatientes de la paz las masacres de
los jóvenes
pues han crecido en colombia en el
gobierno del presidente duque
nosotros esperábamos que hubiese un
posconflicto más tranquilo y el
posconflicto colombiano está haciendo es
muy duro muy doloroso y eso se debe a la
política del presidente duque y el
partido de gobierno que decidieron
echarle gasolina es lejos caro y
prendidos se no agua no extintor a esos
a esos niños prendidos de manera que ese
es el balance es un balance agridulce la
palma para adelante pero la paz ha
tenido una gran interferencia veamos la
otra cara de la moneda eduard rodríguez
también en la ciudad de bogotá cuál es
su balance de esta de estos cinco años
de implementación del acuerdo de paz
pues mire yo creo que el gobierno del
presidente iván duque ha cumplido con
excelencia y con honores lo destacaba
hoy el secretario general de la onu
hasta el propio ex presidente juan
manuel santos pero también creo que la
comunidad internacional se ha entendido
que era un proceso muy difícil porque a
nosotros nos dejaron un país dividido un
país donde sé
algunos amigos y enemigos de la paz lo
que hemos tratado de lograr durante
estos tres años y medio es construir una
paz
estable duradera cumpliéndole a las
bases de las farc cumpliendo los
diferentes mandatos que están y que no
estuvimos de acuerdo en su momento pero
hemos venido construyendo una paz con
legalidad son más de 11 billones de
pesos invertidos en las regiones más
apartadas de colombia pero además de eso
se han hecho recibimos en el gobierno
con 2
y programas de implementación nosotros
cumplimos los 16 y de esta manera pues
creo que se ha venido construyendo una
paz estable duradera no obstante de
todas las falacias y todas las cosas que
nos debemos a proceso incluyendo que no
se han entregado por ejemplo las rutas
del narcotráfico que no se ha reparado
integralmente a las víctimas y son los
pendientes de los cuales pues vamos a
debatir muy seguramente acá vamos ahora
aquí al estudio de france 24 preguntarle
a nardi vargas a nadie y buenas noches
bienvenida y cuál es su balance cuáles
son sus opiniones al respecto buenas
noches pues definitivamente hay que
decir que el proceso de paz ha sido muy
favorable para el país
al menos en tres dimensiones creo yo una
es la situación humanitaria en
definitiva hay una nueva ola de
violencia no obstante los niveles de
victimización han bajado hay homicidios
pero son menos homicidios de los que
habían en el momento de digamos más
álgido del conflicto armado hay masacres
pero son - hay secuestros pero son - y
creo que cualquier vía que se salva en
todo caso se lo debemos a este acuerdo
de paz en segundo lugar creo que vale la
pena resaltar en la el restablecimiento
de derechos de las víctimas que ha
tenido un alcance no sólo respecto al
reconocimiento de hechos victimizan test
a través del sistema de verdad justicia
y reparación sino también el
reconocimiento de las mismas víctimas en
sí mismas si hoy se estaba pensando en
la apertura de un caso sobre violencia
sexual pero está el de reclutamiento
está ante secuestro digamos eso es un
fenómeno sin antecedentes y se lo
debemos a este acuerdo de paz y en
tercer lugar creo que este acuerdo
permitió poner en la agenda del país
otros temas históricamente se ha hablado
siempre de la guerra y del conflicto
armado y era un poco el tema para poner
presidente hoy el país está hablando de
otros temas está hablando de corrupción
está hablando de la economía del
desarrollo y eso es porque de alguna
manera el país también está tratando de
pasar esa página
y en eso concuerdo con león este
gobierno tenía poca voluntad para
implementar los acuerdos y estos logros
hubieran podido ser más profundos
el resurgimiento de nuevos grupos de
fortalecimiento de grupos anteriores se
debe a la falta de voluntad o de
capacidad del gobierno para manejar la
situación de seguridad a nivel local ya
nivel nacional de encontrar estrategias
y el restablecimiento de los derechos a
las víctimas pudiera ser mucho más
eficaz si desde el comienzo del gobierno
no hubiera querido ponerle un poco
obstat tantos obstáculos a la gp y
respecto al tema de protesta social pues
ya vemos que también ha habido como una
situación mal gerencia la gente vale la
pena explicar para los televidentes
fuera de las fronteras colombianas en la
justicia especial para la paz creada
para
realizar ya lo dice el nombre de
justicia y juzgar en el marco de este
acuerdo de acuerdo de paz le pregunto a
eduard rodríguez en la capital
colombiana que le dice usted a estas
personas ya estas opiniones que han
quedado aquí sobre la mesa sobre quienes
creen que el gobierno del presidente de
duke no ha acelerado un poco no ha
llevado por buena marcha la
implementación del acuerdo de paz que se
le puede decir cómo explicarles la
perspectiva del gobierno y también
porque una cosa dice el gobierno acá
dentro de las fronteras colombianas pero
otra cosa dice el presidente de duke
cuando está fuera del país y quiere
vender los avances del proceso de paz
como propios en organismos
internacionales como la onu
o no que fue mal intencionado haber
politizado es el proceso de paz todos
los colombianos queríamos la paz una paz
con justicia donde hoy la jurisdicción
especial para la paz no ha dictado una
sola sentencia pero yo también digo que
la política se hace es con hechos y no
con discursos y lo claro es que sea
reparado 434 mil 387 víctimas del
conflicto durante esto durante este año
o menos durante estos tres años mucho
más de lo que reparo juan manuel santos
en todos sus ocho años se ha hecho un
trabajo
en los
en los 70 que son los espacios donde las
padres estaban para que aquellas
personas o aquellos ciudadanos que se
reintegraron a la vida civil tuviesen
oportunidades es así que todos hoy
tienen seguridad social pero además de
seguridad social tienen un trabajo
tienen un proyecto productivo y todo
esto están saliendo y entendiendo que la
legalidad y que la vida pues legal vale
la pena en ese orden de ideas yo creo
que me pues entiendo sus animadversiones
pero creo que insisto que la paz la
tenemos que construir es con hechos y no
con discursos y no criticando criticando
y criticando sino otorgando soluciones y
planteando soluciones que es lo que
requiere hoy el pueblo colombiano y más
después de esta pandemia leon le
pregunto aquí notamos que hay reclamos
después de estos cinco años sigue
habiendo reclamos por parte del gobierno
de turno por parte de los integrantes
del partido comunes que eran integrantes
de la extinta guerrilla de las farc
reclamos también por parte de los
ciudadanos
esto lo que evidencia es que colombia
sigue siendo un país completamente
desunido no hay un interés común por
sacar este proyecto de paz adelante un
proyecto que tomara alrededor de unos 15
a 20 años en concluir o por lo menos
implementarse por completo y no se está
buscando el bien común se buscan son los
intereses particulares de cada uno que
piensa usted
es cierto lo interpretan muy bien
colombia es un país dividido un país en
que debate el tema de la paz donde pues
hubo una gente que le ha puesto a un
acuerdo a una salida negociada
y bueno que firmó un acuerdo con la
guerrilla de las farc y había una
contradicción con ese acuerdo muchas
críticas a ese acuerdo y puede ser la
ciudad que viene se obtiene un punto de
debate y en un punto digamos el uribismo
pues la ciudadanía apoyo al uribismo en
el plebiscito voto no por una estrecha
diferencia pero se opuso a muchas de las
cosas del acuerdo hoy eso se ha volteado
hoy la mayoría de la sociedad colombiana
está en acuerdo con él con el proceso de
paz el uribismo el presidente duque el
partido del gobierno el centro
democrático y esa coalición de gobierno
está en las encuestas muy mal
y lo ha hecho muy mal como gobierno y
hoy en día la gente está más en favor de
la paz y es lo que ha salvado el proceso
de la justicia opuesto al intento del
gobierno de acabar con ese proceso de
paz sería para o firme ha habido una
oposición dura contra las decisiones del
gobierno de acabar con la epoc o la
comisión de la verdad y él es la
ciudadanía y la comunidad internacional
la que llevan este proceso adelante y yo
sí creo que sí el uribismo y en el caso
de édgar rodríguez que es una persona
muy inteligente es una persona con
muchos argumentos y el uribismo
finalmente da una vuelta a italia a
discutir cómo llevar este proceso pasa
adelante el país ha ganado mucho habría
ganado mucho y nos tenemos que unir
alrededor de la paz
podemos discutir una u otra cosa sobre
la paz nos dimos que unirnos para sacar
al país de la violencia para ofrecerle
un nuevo camino a colombia nadie le
preguntó michael ha estudiado france24
para hacer un poco análisis más general
de este acuerdo
precisamente este pacto alcanzado entre
el gobierno colombiano de momento y las
farc pasó a la historia mundial como un
ejemplo de un acuerdo de paz una
implementación de 15 años
allí en este documento trataron de
abarcar todos los frentes políticos y
sociales que era lo que prácticamente
justificaba la aparición de las
guerrillas y sus luchas sociales
si es un ejemplo para el resto del mundo
porque colombiano lo vi así porque
colombia no siente orgullo por este
acuerdo de paz y no simplemente más
rápido no se pone en marcha y no hay
unión en el país es que pareciera que
los colombianos les costará un poco
pensar en llegar a tener paz yo creo que
tiene que ver con qué colombia lleva
mucho tiempo sumida en la violencia
antes del conflicto armado una violencia
política muy larga de partidos y a
colombia ya los colombianos quizás nos
cuesta un poco darnos cuenta y entender
que si hay una posibilidad de encontrar
una salida negociada más aún cuando
actores políticos han buscado encontrar
diferentes excusas y diferentes
oportunidades para para criticar para
buscar que el camino de la negociación
no se dé entonces
siento también que
los frutos de la paz no son frutos que
quizás se recojan de manera tan rápida
tenemos los ejemplos de otros países en
centroamérica que llevan más de 20 años
en implementación de acuerdos en áfrica
en medio oriente que están que firmaron
acuerdos e incluso más demás más
sencillos de implementar y que aún están
en ese proceso entonces
el acuerdo que se firmó en colombia es
ambicioso y recogía diferentes elementos
que quizás no son tan tan palpables en
el momento tuve del momento puedes ver
la desmovilización y el deber y el de
los de los excombatientes como una
muestra precisa y urgente pero hay otros
temas como la reforma agraria como la
reforma política que se demoran más en
evidenciar como las oportunidades y
estoy de acuerdo con león también en eso
de que si bien en el momento hubo el
debate y hubo quizás la duda de los
colombianos para
afrontar sea una negociación y firmar el
acuerdo de paz hoy colombia ve los
frutos y el hecho por ejemplo de que se
reduzcan los homicidios o que se reduzca
la crisis humanitaria ya hace hace que
los colombianos e incluso se movilicen
en las calles para firmar ese acuerdo yo
creo que hoy no es el mismo contexto que
se vivía en el momento en que tuvimos
que decidir en ese plebiscito y en eso
de pronto si puede haber un poco más
señas de unión entre la sociedad
colombiana entorno acuerdo de paz
diferente comparándolo con 2016 tal vez
yo creo que si además quiero agregar
algo y es que hoy colombia puede ver que
es muy difícil ganar a partir de la
violencia o la salida militar hoy es más
fácil decir la única salida es
negociando y buscan una salida digamos
que nos beneficia todos edward en la
ciudad de bogotá algo que es claro a lo
largo de estos cinco años de
implementación es que la violencia se ha
incrementado en algunas regiones del
país
ln que es otra guerrilla ha ganado
terreno también un grupo armado
delincuencial conocido como el clan del
golfo ha ganado terreno también se
fortalecieron las disidencias que están
encabezadas precisamente por iván
márquez un ex integrante de las farc que
se acogió al acuerdo luego decidió
abandonarlo y regresar a las armas
que decirle a la comunidad internacional
de en torno a este incremento de la
violencia a la muerte de los líderes
sociales y de los líderes
medioambientales
pues mire yo creo que la comunidad
internacional hay que decirle que una
sola vida uno lo tiene que poner a
pensar porque para nosotros la vida es
sagrada y aquí nosotros lo que hemos
tratado de hacer es llegar a una
autoridad y por eso hemos construido la
paz con legalidad si algo queda claro en
colombia es que ninguna ideología de
izquierda a derecha es una justa causa
para hacerle daño a un ser humano pero
también que aquellos que le cumplieron a
la paz hoy y que están en la legalidad
tienen frutos y frutos para tener una
vida digna para tener una reivindicación
y para seguir trabajando por el bien del
país ahora bien quiero decir esto porque
si bien es cierto lln sigue delinquiendo
lo está haciendo desde venezuela y este
gobierno también ha utilizado la
constitución y la ley para darle los
golpes más duros al narcotráfico prueba
de eso es la captura de otoniel prueba
de eso es la neutralización de más de
280 cabecillas que antes eran de la
antiguas parc que no le cumplieron al
proceso que quería seguir
o tráfico y que están en la cárcel o
fueron neutralizados porque se
convirtieron digamos que en
organizaciones criminales al margen de
la ley así que la autoridad y la lo que
dice la constitución y la ley también
tiene un efecto en la construcción de
paz porque quedó el sinsabor de que si
había impunidad era lo que nosotros
tanto advertíamos pues algunos iban a
seguir delinquiendo como ocurrió
efectivamente verbigracia santrich que
siguió delinquiendo que siguió con el
narcotráfico y le tocó escaparse junto
con iván márquez para venezuela y desde
allí pretenden seguir delinquiendo cosa
que nosotros hemos venido combatiendo
con todo el peso de la ley leon también
en la ciudad de bogotá usted qué piensa
ha sido tan buena el desempeño en esta
lucha contra la violencia el incremento
de violencia en zonas como por ejemplo
el sur del país en el
pacifico la costa del pacífico que es
una zona selvática en colombia y que hay
poca presencia del estado colombiano que
piensa usted
pues es que la desgracia digamos del del
gobierno del presidente de lo que es que
no tiene ni una mano
pero ofrecer una salida negociada
al conflicto ni tiene eficacia en la
apuesta de seguridad aquí tuvimos en el
pasado
22 experiencias una con uribe que fue
una persona que aplicó una política de
mano dura de respuesta a las fuerzas
guerrilleras y logró contener las hay
que reconocer eso en una estrategia de
seguridad eficaz
y claro con los costos de derechos
humanos enorme y todos luego vino santos
que tenía una apuesta y reconciliación
de paz y fue eficaz en esto porque se
redujeron todos los fenómenos de
violencia se redujeron pero entramos al
peor de los mundos estamos en un mundo
en el cual la ln crece
narcotráfico se expande y los grupos de
la violencia organizada
también
de digamos del crimen organizado crecen
las disidencias crecen y no hay una
respuesta
excepto actos aislados como la muerte de
tony en la captura detenida de la muerte
de algunos vivientes del heleno pero
todas estas cosas empezaron otra vez a
crecer y no hay una respuesta militar no
hay una estrategia militar para
contenerlos entonces estamos en el peor
de los mundos ni una propuesta de
seguridad ni una estrategia eficaz
militarmente ese es el balance del
gobierno y la ciudadanía no sabe por eso
es que el gobierno el presidente del que
tiene el 20 por ciento de las encuestas
el 25 por ciento de las encuestas por
eso es que el presidente el ex
presidente
uribe está en el peor momento de su vida
está en una baja y en un rechazo del 70
por ciento en muchos líos judiciales
ese es el va cobrar la ciudadanía la
ineficacia este gobierno es enorme ni la
paz ni la guerra ninguna de las dos
cosas seguían y estamos perdiendo mucho
tiempo en este proceso de reconciliación
y lo que queremos llamar la atención es
que un nuevo gobierno un nuevo gobierno
tiene que retomar el camino de la
reconciliación el camino del proceso de
paz cumplir cabalmente los dos centrales
del acuerdo eran la reforma la reforma
agraria y la reforma política ninguna de
esas dos cosas se ha avanzado un ápice
en nuestros dos caminos bueno hay quedan
dos temas de los pocos avances de
acuerdo a nuestro invitado que ha tenido
en esos dos aspectos pero yo le pregunto
a nadie aquí en el estudio de france 24
y también para ver un poco la cara
positiva este acuerdo y es que podemos
destacar de los puntos que fueron
pactados cuáles están avanzando en el
reconocimiento de las víctimas
algunos de los invitados dicen que no
hay un avance en la restitución de las
tierras en la reforma agraria en el
avance político pero las farc hoy en día
están convertidas en un partido político
comunes y ya ha participado en comicios
donde la gente ha votado si les ha
gustado las propuestas que hacen en que
se puede destacar y que podemos sacar
positivo para hacer balance del lado
positivo del acuerdo a ver lo que yo
crees que definitivamente el país si
gana con el acuerdo final pero otro
balance muy diferente es si tú quieres
ver si el acuerdo se ha implementado de
la manera en que fue pactado y yo creo
que hay el balance es totalmente
negativo creo que podemos rescatar
pequeños aspectos de cada uno de los
puntos si podemos ir por reforma
política claro tenemos ya no tenemos una
guerrilla tenemos un partido y está la
posibilidad de que las víctimas
participen en el legislativo salvo por
la posición del gobierno pero está
digamos todavía esa y esa es digamos una
de las deudas que se tiene con las con
las víctimas y con las regiones de esas
de estas personas que han sido
victimizados por tanto tiempo entonces
creo que hay algo por por rescatar de la
reforma agraria y un poco se tenía la
idea de que hubiera una legalización de
tierras con el catastro multipropósito
eso andando muy lento pero bueno
finalmente empezó a andar la inserción
por ejemplo la la reincorporación fue
totalmente exitosa la reincorporación
que tiene a todos los ex combatientes en
la mayoría de casos con proyectos
productivos en la legalidad una pequeña
minoría realmente está vinculada a
fenómenos de violencia pero la gran
mayoría hoy está cumpliendo y siento
también que
hubo también una especie de
reconciliación creo yo
o más bien de la que la sociedad
colombiana se mire al espejo y pueda
reconocer en las víctimas a las víctimas
siento que la comisión de la verdad la
unidad de búsqueda en la justicia
especial para la paz le han mostrado a
colombia el dolor que ha sentido mucha
gente víctima del conflicto que digamos
pasó un poco desapercibida porque el
tema era la seguridad entonces creo que
hoy las víctimas han cobrado este
protagonismo que se les debía de
anteriores gobiernos
leon en la ciudad de bogotá a su balance
positivo rápidamente que ya llegamos a
la parte final del programa
y hay cosas que son ciertas la
reincorporación tiene muchos éxitos pero
claro hay tropiezos también procesos
productivos de largo plazo están todavía
en veremos también hay los pellets hay
programas de desarrollo en muchas zonas
el señor archila que está al frente de
ese proceso ha tenido éxito en muchas
cosas eso son logros importantes pero el
mayor logro el mayor logro es que la paz
como propósito nacional se ha asentado
en el país ya es muy difícil que alguien
alce la mano contra las salidas
negociadas que alguien se oponga a ellas
los que se han opuesto a ellas están en
una minoría están retrocediendo están a
la defensiva tienen que salir a hablar
de que el acuerdo de paz es importante
se le honra de cualquier nombre o
apellido
eduardo usted nos mencionaba algunos de
los logros que ha tenido el presidente
duque a lo largo de estos años de
gobierno en la implementación no lo voy
a hacer la pregunta en torno a lo
positivo porque usted ha mencionado
algunos de los aspectos y de los logros
de este gobierno
quiero preguntarle desde su perspectiva
oficialista hay reclamos a la ex
guerrilla de las farc hay reclamos en
torno a la implementación par para desde
ese lado del acuerdo qué opinión tienen
ustedes
es por supuesto un 1 los reclamos que ya
lo decía el principio es el tema de las
rutas del narcotráfico
hay temas que son desafortunados por
parte de la guerrilla de las farc como
decir que no obligaban a hacer trabajos
forzosos a los secuestrados sino que
pues como lo dijo ayer uno de sus
dirigentes que eran lo hacían por
recrearse eso es completamente falso
como tampoco han digamos que entregado
toda la información o lo no han pedido
perdón a los niños reclutados y en ese
orden y des creo que hay muchas
falencias
la primera sentencia y creo que mientras
que algunos se dediquen a ser
prepotentes ya generar su línea
discursiva pues no vamos a lograr
credibilidad en ese proceso de hecho yo
hice un acto legislativo para que en
colombia nunca más el narcotráfico y el
secuestro fuera
conexo con el delito político eso ya
está mandado a recoger de tal manera que
aquí lo que tenemos es un gran desafío
institucional para que se cumpla por
parte de las farc con lo que ellos
plantearon porque aún solamente han
entregado 34.000 millones de pesos
mientras que el gobierno ha invertido
cerca de 11 millones de pesos en el
proceso hay muchas deudas que las farc
tiene que reflexionar y colaborar para
construir una verdadera paz
bueno pues ya me quedan pocos minutos
para terminar el programa paso a hacer
las conclusiones y creo que la
conclusión más sensata de todo esto de
acuerdo es qué va a pasar en el futuro
cercano con este acuerdo de paz en su
implementación en colombia' la
proyección es unos 15 a 20 años de
implementación llevamos cinco ya que
piensa usted nardy en torno a lo que
pueda pasar en el futuro cercano pues
realmente el tema de la implementación
depende de muchos actores depende del
gobierno depende de la sociedad incluso
en la comunidad internacional ha
demostrado el protagonismo que tiene en
un proceso tan relevante como el que se
enfrenta a colombia yo creo que de parte
de la sociedad y la comunidad
internacional hay una decisión tomada
por la paz por jugársela por la
implementación y enemigos de la paz en
lo social colombiano yo pensaría que no
hay enemigo yo creo que hay matices
respecto a algunos temas pero hoy nadie
se negaría a decir que vamos a ir por la
paz y creo que hoy también algunos
matices que se presentaban hace un par
de años han sido diluidos tantos mitos y
tantas
si se quiere mentiras que se dijeron en
su momento hoy han sido comprobadas como
tal realmente el tema que queda y es el
gran debate que hay es el gobierno que
se queda pues el que está digamos ya no
hacer más de lo que ya hizo porque su
voluntad está demostrada pero el
gobierno que llega así tiene una una
gran tarea y ojalá se la juegue por la
implementación es decir colombia se
enfrenta a elecciones presidenciales en
el 2022 edward tengo un minuto para
finalizar el programa 30 segundos o
conclusión que sigue para este proyecto
de paz yo yo creo que el país tiene que
unirse alrededor de unos propósitos yo
mismo ha dialogado con la guerrilla o
bueno con los integrantes de las farc en
el congreso y creo que tenemos que
unirnos en propósitos comunes uno de
ellos es la diferenciación dentro de la
justicia especial para la paz con los
militares que es que juzgan los
militares tenga experiencia y creo que
aquí lo que hay que construir es
un diálogo al interior de lo que nos une
y no de lo que nos divide y eso es el
futuro que colombia de hecho en mi
criterio está pensando léon su
conclusión 30 segundos
implementar el acuerdo integralmente de
paz normalizar las relaciones con
venezuela tratar pacíficamente la
protesta social y también ofrecer salida
negociada a la ln y reformar la policía
esas son tareas en función de la paz que
tienen que hacerse desde el próximo
gobierno y entrar un último punto entrar
en una ola de
legalización de las drogas el
narcotráfico y las mafias siguen siendo
un peso muy grande sobre el papel del
país y la único camino es la
legalización pues al león a edward ya
nadie a quien él estudia france24 les
agradezco por haber compartido con
nosotros sus opiniones y su análisis en
torno a este tema que nos convoca hoy el
acuerdo de paz en colombia' cinco años
de esa firma entre el gobierno y la ex
guerrilla de las farc ustedes puede
seguir dejando sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
siguen con nuestra programación buenas
noches
[Música]